so i'm excited today to talk to you
about how we can use human input in
order to develop robust ai systems
and so if we look at our world today
we're increasingly coming in contact
with ai systems whether it be through
social media recommender systems the
online advertisements that we see as we
browse the web
additionally behind the scenes more and
more we're starting to see robots
working in warehouses and factories
fulfilling orders helping us deal with
supply chain issues and a lot of
companies are starting to think about
how can we bring robots and other ai
systems into hospitals into our homes
into grocery stores as well as in to our
roads and driving on our streets
and i think in the coming days and in
the future these a systems are going to
become even more prevalent
and so one of the things that really
motivates my research is this idea that
we want to get these robots and ais
systems out there in the real world
interacting with people learning from
them adapting to their preferences and
needs
and so one of the big problems that
these systems face
is what i'm going to call value
alignment which is basically how do we
get these ai systems to do what we as
humans actually want them to do
and you might say well maybe that's not
that big of a problem you know i'm
pretty good at writing down objective
functions having ai systems optimize
them and a lot of
objectives that we think about in
robotics or machine learning do on the
surface seem pretty well defined so we
can think about classification we say
okay we just want to maximize our
accuracy we'll just collect a lot of
data label it have a test set
maybe that's a pretty simple objective
similarly we might think about like a
motion planning problem where it seems
pretty simple we can define a start the
goal maybe some obstacles we want to
avoid and then the objective also seems
pretty clear we want to go from a to b
without colliding with something
we also might think about robot grasping
as a pretty simple you know problem to
specify an objective for so this is
showing some of our work recently where
we're looking at how do we grasp unknown
objects that may be adversarial and here
we do give the robot just a very simple
objective of a reward of plus one every
time it is able to successfully grasp
the object a word of zero otherwise and
we use band algorithms to allow the
system to iteratively over time improve
its performance
but i think if we dig a little bit
deeper into these problems we'll see
that things maybe aren't quite as well
defined as we they initially think so if
we think about classification i'd argue
that no one really cares about just
maximizing average accuracy there's
often subtle nuances in terms of how
much we care about true positives or
false positives and false negatives for
example a driving system we wanted to be
like pretty
good at detecting like stop lights and
stop signs but we may allow for some
error in terms of misclassifying a car
as a truck
and ideally we don't want to just have
systems that can you know recognize
things in image but we want to have
systems that can drive down busy streets
in ways that are safe and efficient
and think about what kind of objective
function we'd have to write down to get
an ai system to do this is actually very
challenging because of all the different
tradeoffs and factors involved
similarly if we think about something
like a motion planning problem things
start to get a lot more difficult if we
were maybe carrying a hot liquid now we
have all these very complex constraints
we have to take into account and what if
rather than just moving the end effector
we're now moving a person from point a
to point b now these constraints are
really like depend on the person often
very hard to write down and so this
problem actually becomes very hard to
specify
and then think about grasping you know
what does it actually mean to grasp an
object successfully the scratch looks
okay turns out it's not
and really what makes the grass good
depends on how we're going to use this
grass about the affordances that we're
going to do and really like we want to
move beyond just you know picking up an
object to do something useful like
coming into these kids room helping them
organize clean up their room
and you know we don't want it to just
you know maybe sweep all the toys under
the rug push them into the closet i
tried that once as a kid my mom told me
no it doesn't match my specification but
i think she would have trouble you know
writing down her actual specification i
would as well of what does it mean to
organize nicely and you know put away
the toys in this room
so i'd argue that if we think about the
problems that we're really excited about
as roboticists and ai and machine
learning learning researchers that these
objectives are often really hard to
specify
and i'd go further and say that i would
say a robust ai is really human-centered
ai kind of going back to these problems
we really need some interaction with the
person to help us figure out what these
systems should be doing
so i'm going to define robustness as
acceptable behavior in the presence of
uncertainty and unusual circumstances
i'd like to highlight these keywords
here acceptable behavior
i think this really brings us back to
this idea of value alignment
which is you know how do we get these
systems to do what we as people really
want apologies on the link
and so how does this work though when
we're learning from people this is often
very difficult right people are noisy we
make mistakes
often human input is ambiguous and
looking at what people did in hindsight
often just looks very irrational at
times but i'd argue that rather than
trying to like minimize human input or
treat human input as a disturbance we
really want to build ai systems from the
ground up to think about how can we
leverage human input how can we deal
with these uncertainties and ambiguities
in order to get our a systems to behave
the way we want
so kind of in a nutshell like the one
sentence summary of the work that i do
is i try and incorporate efficiently
human input into both the theory and the
practice of robust ai systems
and
kind of at high level
i look at these three different areas so
human factors robotics and machine
learning working within the union of all
them and more often than not in the
intersection of these so i've been
looking to work on a variety of really
fun and fascinating problems ranging
from human swarm interactions how do we
get humans to manage these multi-agent
collectives looking at shared autonomy
assistive robotics autonomous driving
how do we get these cars to navigate
roads alongside humans using models of
human intent as well as looking at
robust policy optimization so how can we
develop algorithms that are robust to
uncertainty and really hedge against
this uncertainty that they might have
a lot of my work is focused on what
we've talked about this idea of value
alignment or learning reward functions
models of human intent
as well as looking at ideas for
interactive imitation learning and
robust grasping and kidding of objects
so i don't have time to talk about all
these today but i'd like to focus on
these three topics
under this kind of larger umbrella of
value alignment how do we learn
specifications for a systems from human
input
and there's these kind of fundamental
challenges that i'm going to talk about
today and one is how do we estimate
uncertainty so if i'm learning from a
person
how do i
estimate and really think about you know
my uncertainty
and the different hypotheses that might
explain the human behavior also talk
about how can we be robust to that
uncertainty
how we hedge against risk and hedge our
bets and then finally how do we actively
reduce the uncertainty how can we ask
targeted queries that allow these a
system to reduce uncertainty and really
figure out what they need to know
and so a lot of my work builds on this
idea of reinforcement learning which i
think most of you are probably familiar
with where we have an agent interacting
with environment taking actions
receiving rewards and observations
and as a lot of you probably know this
idea of reward engineering is actually
quite difficult trying to figure out
what reward function we should place
there to get the desired behavior is
often challenging that often is this
interactive process where an engineer is
going to you know write down a reward
function optimize it say oh no let me
tweak a few weights here and there and
this is often a painful process
and there's a lot of tasks that we could
say
that probably showing is maybe easier
than telling so driving is a classic
example where it's really hard for me to
sit down and write down a reward
function that describes all the
important things for driving but it's
very easy for me for for me to hop into
a car and show you an example of you
know pretty good driving behavior
and so a lot of my work looks at this
idea of inverse reinforcement learning
where we're now taking the role of the
observer we're watching a human interact
with the environment we assume that they
have some underlying cost function or
reward function they're trying to
optimize and then the question here is
you know why did the human do what they
did what was the human's reward function
ideally we want to learn this function
you know we can take observations
actions and map it to the scalar real
valued reward signal telling us how good
we think the human thinks these actions
or observations are
and so you might ask well why not just
directly imitate if we're interested in
getting behavior that's aligned with
what the human does maybe we can just
watch the human see what actions they
take based on different observations i'm
just asking what would the human have
done in this situation
and here we might want to learn like a
policy right that maps from observations
into actions just directly using
standard supervised learning
and this is you know well studied and
often you know works really well it's
called behavioral cloning
but there are cases where we probably
just don't want robots going through the
motions so this is a funny video i found
of kind of this like satirical instance
of robot just going through the motions
just kind of like i know what i should
do here and there
giving someone breakfast pouring the
milk now i'm going to pick up the spoon
and feed the person
and so this is designed to be funny but
i think it drives home the point that we
don't want ai systems or robots that
just go through the motions and don't
understand why they're doing anything
and this is not just satire so we've
actually seen this in the lab so this is
a project that i've been working on with
an undergrad where we're learning how to
do these assistive feeding and assistive
care tasks with a human and we tried
using behavioral cloning where we gave a
couple really good demonstrations to the
robot and these and then we did
behavioral cloning to learn a policy
however when things changed a little bit
when the human's head is in a slightly
different position the robot starts in
slightly different position the robot
just doesn't really know what to do it's
just kind of learned to mimic the
motions it knows it should get close to
the human but because things are a
little bit different than what it was
trained on it just diverges and ends up
just kind of hovering over the person's
head just totally missing the mark
however if we learn a reward function
that actually maps what the human really
wants and allows us to optimize to
achieve that objective then we can get
really good performance and actually
accomplish a task even in different
situations
so hopefully i've convinced you now that
infrared human intent is important for
robustness by the end of the talk i'm
actually going to return to this idea of
behavioral cloning and talk about how we
can use human interactions to make that
more robust as well
so we've talked a lot about this idea of
learning reward functions
from human demonstrations that we can
then turn into a policy via policy
optimization
and this idea like we talked about
called inverse reinforcement learning
but there are some common problems with
a lot of these approaches
one is that typically prior work
couldn't do much better than the
demonstrator and this is often by design
a lot of these systems are trying to
find a reward function
that if i optimize it leads to the
behavior that i saw in the demonstrator
and so we're trying to find a reward
function that rationalizes what the
demonstrator did you know warts and all
so if the demonstrator makes some
mistakes we're going to say hey that was
probably intentional
and we can't really do much better
another problem is that these problems
are often hard to scale the complex
problems because often they have on the
inner loop some kind of an mdp solver
so something that's running optimal
control or reinforcement learning over
and over again
so we had this idea back in 2019 that we
could use pre-ranked demonstrations in
order to try and address these problems
one thing that's nice is if we have a
set of ranked demonstrations so
example a which is better than example b
which is better than example c we can
now think of a reward function that
tries to explain that ranking but
potentially allows us to extrapolate and
think about things that might be even
better than the best example we've seen
and what's cool is this is actually
going to turn reward learning now into a
supervised learning problem making
things a lot more efficient and scalable
so we call this approach trajectory
ranked reward extrapolation or t-rex
where the idea is that we're going to
take a set of pre-ranked demonstrations
here's a simulated half sheet
environment the robot is trying to run
to the right and we want to run the
right as far and as fast as it can we
give it a set of examples ranging from
it's just pretty awful scooting out its
face to something that's kind of like a
little toddler that can kind of run
along but occasionally face plans and we
give it about 15 of these examples
ranked and we learn a reward function
and the cool thing is when we optimize
this reward function learn from
sub-optimal behavior we get really good
behavior that runs about twice as fast
and far as the best demonstration that
we've seen
so how does this work so i'd like to
kind of ground things a little bit so
what does actually mean to learn a
reward function so this is a function
right that maps from states s into the
real valued numbers
and it's typically parametrized by
some model represented by theta it could
be like a linear model or a deep neural
network model and so some examples of
states it could be like robot joints
angles and velocities
in this case maybe we'd want a map you
know something like this state to a
positive reward maybe something is face
planting to a negative reward
it could also be short sequences of
images if we're doing a visual task
so maybe it's a short snippet of this
you know agent driving and you can see
here it's passing a few cars so maybe
that's like a good thing here it's
getting passed maybe that's a bad thing
ideally as a designer i don't have to go
in and specify all these numbers but i
can learn
how to map from states to rewards from
data
and so the way trx works
is we have a set of ranked
demonstrations and we're going to focus
on just two of these
and if i prefer trajectory 2 tau 2 over
trajectory 1 well it ought to be the
case that my reward function i'm
learning r sub theta gives a higher
reward to the better ranked trajectory
and a lower reward to the lower ranked
trajectory especially when i accumulate
this reward over these trajectories
that's what's cool is we can now just
train this using a standard bradley
terry pairwise ranking loss
i like to think about this in terms of
kind of a binary classification problem
where you could think about the logits
as the accumulated rewards on these two
trajectories and we can equivalently
minimize a cross-entropy loss
and so this allows us to back propagate
into a deep neural network
and train it to match up with these
rankings and learn a reward function
that satisfies those labels
and so what's cool about this is that
given pre-ranked demonstrations reward
learning is now just a standard
supervised learning problem we've
removed the mtp solver from the inner
loop making this very scalable and
tractable
and so this allows us to
you know extend this work to learn from
offline demonstrations for the first
time to do complex tasks like atari
games where we don't have access to the
score but we're given a set of 12 ranked
demonstrations where this is the best
demonstration in our set and you can see
that the demonstrator here is you're
doing an okay job but occasionally
they're going to ram into cars
and then we learn a t-rex policy from
this
which does much better so if we look at
the game scores which the agent doesn't
have access to we can see it's achieving
a score of 520 much better than the best
demonstration
so you might ask you know what if what
if you don't have explicit preference
labels and so we've also looked at ideas
of learning from a learner so if i can
watch a learner over time who's maybe
like on average improving we can
actually use the time stamps of
different trajectories that we've seen
and this actually works pretty well to
give us labels we've also looked at work
on automatically generating preference
labels by adding noise into a behavioral
cloned policy
and so i'd like to kind of take a step
back though because i think one of the
cool things about this is that
we now have these ai systems that can
efficiently infer human intent from
suboptimal demonstrations
which is something that we see that
people can do from a very young age so
for lots of studies showing that the
humans even from like age like one or
one and a half can kind of tell what a
human wanted to do even when the human
you know makes a mistake and so you can
see there's like obviously a lot of cues
going on here there's like facial cues
kind of verbal cues but this you know
kid says hey i know what you're trying
to do let me help you out here and he's
able to put this block on there and so i
think it's really cool that we have
we're starting to see ai systems that
can do similar things that can learn
from some helpful demonstrations and
kind of infer human intent even if it's
not you know optimally shown
so i'd like to now talk about how do we
estimate uncertainty
so we talked about t-rex which is a cool
of learning reward functions from human
input from sub-optimal rank
demonstrations but it's only learning
this single reward function estimate
this maximum likelihood estimate and so
this can lead to problems so we found
that when we trained on some human
demonstrations of mrs pac-man this is
actually what the agent learned to do
so i learned that there's this cool
little loophole that you can go through
this tunnel and it confuses the ghosts
really badly and so they never eat you
you can live forever but it never
actually learned to like eat the pellets
it just learned that hey dying is really
bad living for a long time is good let
me optimize that
similarly for this space game where
you're like driving a spaceship trying
to shoot enemy ships and discover this
cool hack that you can like mash your
keys back and forth and you stay out of
the enemy firing lanes you live for a
really long time you never get hit
awesome i'm doing really well
and
not really though and so you can see how
these are over fit to the spurious
correlations in the data while it may be
true that better ranked demonstrations
do last longer maybe do avoid ghosts
more that's not really the only
hypothesis that explains this data and
there's no
way of having these con
on this consideration of alternative
hypotheses if we're just learning this
maximum likelihood estimate so what
would we like to do well ideally we'd
like to be bayesian we'd like to learn
an entire distribution over likely
reward functions given this human data
so we can think about uncertainty and
risk and entertain multiple reasons that
might explain this data
and so this is a well studied field
called bayesian word inference or
beijing inverse reinforcement learning
where we're trying to
essentially learn this posterior
distribution the
probability density function over reward
functions given human data and we can
use your favorite bayes rule to look at
this in terms of a likelihood function
what's the probability of this data
given a reward function hypothesis along
with the prior
so here r is a reward function d is the
human data and ideally we'd like to be
able to sample from this posterior
distribution and get lots of hypotheses
that match the human data
and typically when you do this the kind
of crux of the problem is figuring out
this likelihood function what's the
likelihood of the human producing data d
given the hypothesis that made their
optimizing reward function r
and so to ground this a little more
let's say i'm in a certain state the
demonstrator takes action a but there
were these alternative actions they
could have taken
and so one common way of formulating
this likelihood function is to say well
the likelihood of this state action pair
is going to be equal to
this ratio here where on the numerator i
have the action the demonstrator took
and then the q value representing the
goodness of taking that action and then
acting optimally thereafter and dividing
the denominator by the goodness of all
the other actions that the demonstrator
might have taken so i'm kind of
performing this counter factual and
saying how good is this action you
showed me versus the other alternatives
under this reward function hypothesis
but if we think about trying to find
these q values
for different reward functions this ends
up being intractable pretty quickly
because basically it requires solving an
optimal control of reinforcement
learning for every hypothesis i want to
evaluate
so we wanted to try and make this more
efficient and so our idea was that we
could do fast bayesian inference by
taking advantage of these two components
so first we're going to learn this low
dimensional latent space that we're
going to pre-train so we're going to
learn this nice embedding space to make
things more efficient so we can go from
high dimensional inputs down to a lower
dimensional space that will make our
bayesian inference more tractable
and second we're going to use a
preference based likelihood in order to
make this calculation a lot faster and
avoid having to run a reinforcement
learning algorithm every time we want to
evaluate a new reward function
so we call this approach bayesian reward
extrapolation or bayesian rex where the
idea is that we're going to do this kind
of feature pre-training to learn an
embedding space so we have the same
input as before with t-rex we have these
ranked demonstrations and they're going
to be in some high-dimensional space
maybe image spaces here and basically
what we're going to do is we're going to
feed these into a deep neural network
convolutional neural network that's
going to embed them down to a lower
dimensional space
so we have this future embedding that
we're trying to train and the question
is how do we how do we train this
embedding
and so we've looked at several different
ways of doing this one way you can do
this is have several different
self-supervised or unsupervised task
losses
so for example we looked at trying like
a variational autoencoder that tries to
map from an image embed it down and then
reconstruct we also looked at ideas like
temporal distance so given the
embeddings of two different states from
the same trajectory can i predict how
far apart they are as well as doing
inverse dynamics and forward dynamics
all using the same shared future
embedding
but we found that actually just doing
unsupervised or self-supervised training
wasn't as good as when we added a little
bit of actual supervised learning
and interestingly just doing supervised
learning actually didn't do as well as
adding in some unsupervised
self-supervised learning
i think yeah the intuition here that we
have and this is still kind of an open
question of why but i think the reason
is that these self-supervised tasks are
going to learn lots of interesting
features
but they may not be actually relevant to
what the human wants at all whereas if
we just use the supervised training data
we might overfit to spurious
correlations and just hope focus on one
thing that explains the rankings and so
by having this kind of mixture of
auxiliary functions we're able to train
this light in space that
captures a lot of interesting
information relative to a variety of
different possible human intentions and
what's nice is we can now freeze these
weights here and we now have this
feature extractor that works on these
high dimensional inputs
and so this gives us the feature
pre-training and we can now just define
a linear reward function on top of that
so we have these features s
from our latent space and we can define
a reward function as just a linear
combination of these with this weight
vector theta
and so what's cool about this is it's
going to make things really efficient
because we can take these pre-ranked
demonstrations that we have we can embed
them in the latent space just by adding
up the latent space for every state and
adding that all together and this gives
us the set of you know ranked
demonstration essentially feature counts
in this
latent space that we've learned
and so the reason this is important is
because we have a linear reward function
if we looked at what our predicted
trajectory return is
for a trajectory tau we're going to have
to sum up all of the states in that
trajectory well this is essentially if
we put in the linear reward function we
can pull out the theta vector and really
all it is is just this dot product if we
want to predict a trajectory's return we
just take our weight vector hypothesis
dot product with this expected feature
count vector
and so what's cool is this is going to
make our inference really fast so we're
doing markov chain monte carlo inference
where at a high level basically all
we're asking is given a hypothesis for
your reward function given these ranked
demonstrations you've given me how
likely is this
and what's cool is we have these
preference labels right this is kind of
our input data we want to say how likely
is this is this trajectory preference
well if we looked at the predicted
returns
so i have a theta vector i want to say
how likely is it that you were operating
on this reward function well if you were
then probably you would have had a
higher reward for the better range
trajectory and i can quickly calculate
how well this theta vector matches up
with your preferences just via these dot
products
and the only thing i need to like vary
is theta because i've pre-computed
everything else
so this makes it nice we can now use
this likelihood function that's based
off these preferences and with just a
couple dot products we can efficiently
evaluate the likelihood of any
hypothesize reward function without
having any need of touching the mdp no
rollouts no mdp solver
and so this allows us to repeatedly
sample from this posterior distribution
really efficiently
and
this is cool this is the first bayesian
reward inference algorithm that's able
to scale to these visual high
dimensional control tasks and to give
you an idea of the actual efficiency
here so we're able to generate about 10
000 samples of likely reward functions
less than a minute just running on my
laptop no gpus or anything fancy whereas
if i were to use a standard classical
beijing irl approach that would sample a
reward function
run a reinforcement learning algorithm
evaluate a likelihood you were talking
maybe you know five or plus hours for a
single sample
assistant close this allows us to do
this efficient bayesian inference on
these high dimensional control tasks for
the first time
and this works really well so this is
like learning atari breakout game and so
you see here the agent is able to learn
from just a set of
ranked sub-option demonstrations in
order to be able to play the game really
well
and compared to some other approaches so
if you look at the best of the 12
demonstrations these demonstrations
actually never are that good this is
actually a quite complex game when you
start hitting the higher and lower
levels and just running behavioral
cloning it doesn't do that well
you can look at some other approaches
such as a generative adversarial
approach and these methods are often
really unstable and are hard to apply to
these visual domains
if you look at t-rex it does much better
and bayesian rex which is actually
learning this posterior if we take
the
the mean reward function from this
posterior and optimize it we actually
often do even better than just learning
this like emily estimate
and so just using the reward function in
this way like just taking the
expectation of the distribution is not
kind of the best use of having a full
bayesian posterior so we've also looked
at what can you do when you have this
posterior distribution and one of the
nice things you can do is you can come
up with these high confidence
performance bounds given a policy or
trajectory i can now with high
confidence tell you whether this policy
is better than this other policy using
this distribution we've also shown that
we can use this to detect misaligned
reward functions so look at this example
here from this beanwriter example
if i have a distribution over likely
reward functions i can now take a policy
such as this one and i can evaluate it
very efficiently because of this linear
reward function over a variety of
different hypotheses and we found that
looking at the tails of these
distributions actually is a really good
indicator of when this agent is
performing this kind of reward hacking
behavior optimizing a misaligned reward
function because essentially having
really long tails tells me that there
are lots of reward hub function
hypotheses that looked likely given the
data but they might say that this is
really bad
because maybe these other reward
functions hypotheses say that like you
know destroying enemy ships is important
or advancing through the levels and so
by having this distribution we're able
to identify cases where we might be you
know very misaligned
cool so i'd like to now take a step back
and think about
given that we can now estimate these
reward function distributions
how can we be robust to this uncertainty
and so we're going to assume that we can
now sample
a posterior distribution of likely
roller functions given this human data
the question is given that i'm uncertain
over what the true objective is how
should i act how should an ai system act
if it doesn't know its true objective or
reward function ideally we want to have
systems that are robust to this
uncertainty
and so a lot of prior work typically
would optimize you know for a single
reward function maybe it would be like
the most likely reward function or maybe
the expected reward function under a
distribution
and we've seen examples right where the
most likely reward function just like
overfits dispersed correlations is not
what we want
similarly i'd like to argue that we
often don't want to just do well on
expectation so if we think about maybe
like a self-driving car driving down the
road maybe it detects some obstacle
maybe a box in the road and it might be
that you know with high likelihood it
thinks an expectation that you know box
is empty it can just run over it nothing
will happen but there's some chance that
maybe if it runs over the box maybe it
contains some object that might damage
the car or hurt the passengers and so
rather than you know driving through
which might an expectation work the best
because it minimizes you know weaving on
the road it gets you to the destination
a little faster we probably want our
systems to be a little more risk-averse
you know maybe slow down actually avoid
that object i think that's probably what
most of us would do when driving down
this road
and so we turned to finance
to think about how can we deal with this
idea of thinking about risk think about
risk and reward trade-offs because in
computational finance yeah that's really
kind of the name of the game
and there are a couple different metrics
that are often used in finance one is
this idea of a value at risk and so this
is essentially just like a one minus
alpha quantile outcome and so if we're
looking at this random variable x and we
have some distribution the value at risk
is given a certain alpha level is going
to be the level at which we have
say like 95 percent of the distribution
above that point and so if you think
about this in terms of like you know
performance we might be able to say hey
95 of the time my performance is no
worse than x amount so kind of just
taking this like percentile shot
now
this is nice but
it turns out optimizing for value risk
actually ends up being a difficult
problem and it ignores the tails you
know ignores what's going to happen in
this red section maybe in like the five
percent worst case outcomes
and so often what people have been doing
and more and more this is becoming more
popular this idea of conditional value
at risk so we're going to condition on
being kind of in this tail of the
distribution this red shaded portion and
we're going to say given that i'm in
like the 5 worst case outcomes
how much do i expect that what do i
expect to happen so we'll look at this
expectation as we might say that you
know how bad is my performance going to
be an expectation given that it's like
the five percent worst case
and what's cool now is maximizing c bar
ends up being a very tractable
optimization problem and we're actually
taking into account kind of the tails of
this distribution really thinking about
how do we be robust to some of these
kind of worst case outcomes
and so we proposed this approach called
bayesian robust optimization for
imitation learning or broil where
basically what we want to do is we want
to directly optimize the policy to be
maximally robust to a distribution over
reward functions so rather than a
standard rl approach that assumes that i
have this magical reward function that's
given to me that's perfect i can just
optimize that we now say okay let's
let's take a step back let's assume this
reward function isn't perfect in fact
let's just say we have a distribution of
reward functions now we want to optimize
our behavior such that we can maximize
this conditional valid risk when these
reward functions are taken from this
distribution and so the way we do that
is we're going to try and make sure that
we're not performing really poorly under
any one of these reward functions
because that will lead us to have you
know a high conditional valid risk and
what's really cool is we've shown that
you can actually efficiently solve
for a policy that optimizes the
objective just using linear programming
so it's super efficient as long as you
have a discrete mdp so discrete states
discrete actions
and what's even more cool is that you
can actually extend this continuous
states and continuous actions really
easily using a ppo style policy gradient
and so we have some recent work showing
that with just a few changes
to a standard policy gradient algorithm
we can actually now make it
robust to an entire distribution of
reward functions and use kind of all the
standard tricks that we use in our
state-of-the-art reinforcement learning
algorithms to make the scale the
interesting problems
and it's kind of a cute example of this
we've shown that this is really nice for
hedging against multiple objectives so
we looked at this atari boxing game
where there's kind of these competing
objectives where i'm trying to score
points on the opponent but avoid getting
punched myself and we gave some some
awful ranked demonstrations ran bayesian
rex to get a posterior distribution over
likely reward functions
and we evaluated a whole bunch of
different approaches to try and get a
policy so we looked at risk neutral
approaches like behavioral cloning
methods like adversarial imitation
learning there are risk averse versions
of adversarial limitation learning we
looked at maximizing you know the most
likely reward function maybe the mean
reward function
and across the board everything
performed much worse than the broil
approach which is trying to hedge
against its risk kind of playing
whack-a-mole with the different
hypotheses that it might have and really
trying to find a reward function that
performs well across the distribution
allowing it to balance these multiple
competing objectives
and so i think this is really exciting
and i think kind of the high level
take-home message here is that ai
systems that hedge against their
uncertainty are going to be a lot more
robust than ones that try and you know
uniquely identify one reward function
that they think explains the human data
and i think this is really important
because a lot of problems that we think
about are inherently kind of
multi-objective and that's like a
natural way to think about them a
natural way to express them and really
having these methods that can balance
these different objectives is really
important especially if we think about
ideas like aligning behavior to multiple
people it's kind of like multi-agent
value alignment problem i think
extending these ideas that we have for
broil to allow systems to perform well
under multiple people's preferences is
really exciting making sure that we're
not performing really poorly or under
some you know small subset of these
people's values
cool and so with that i'd now like to
pop back up and then move on to this
question of how do we actively reduce
uncertainty because it might be the case
that i just have so much uncertainty
that even if i try and like hedge all my
bets it just kind of leads to something
nonsensical i just really need more
information
so ideally we have these as systems that
can ask for help
i think anyone that's like taught a
class where you know none of the
students respond none of them ask
questions i think it's especially
pertinent in like zoom days when you
like wouldn't even see half the people
in the audience it's really hard to be
able to tailor the information that
you're giving if you're like teaching a
class or giving instruction to someone
they like never ask you questions never
show you what they're uncertain about
and ideally we want our ais systems move
from being passive learners to being
active learners that you know we'll
figuratively raise our hands maybe with
a robot actually
physically raise our hands and ask for
help we want systems that know what they
know but also know what they're
uncertain about and this will allow
people to give the appropriate
information and allow them to learn much
more efficiently
and so the question here that we want to
look at is when should a robot ask for
help
and so when we started thinking about
this one of the things that first came
to mind was that if the robot finds
itself
in a
novel
state
then this is a point where where it
should ask for help so for example maybe
i've given a lot of data of a
self-driving car just self-driving car
you know driving down roads but now you
know it finds itself off-road so because
it's off distribution it's probably
going to make a mistake and so it should
probably ask for help at this point it
should probably call into the person say
hey can you help me out i'm not sure
what i should do
and so it kind of makes sense that novel
states are going to be risky and we
should ask for help there what we also
realized is that there actually are
other states it may not be novel but
still are risky for example you can
think about this like narrow mountain to
pass that i've seen lots of examples of
driving down but i know there's like a
very small margin for error and i know
i'm still like not that great at driving
here and so even though this isn't novel
to me if my policy of performance is not
kind of up to snuff i still might think
this is risky and i might benefit from
some human interventions and some human
help
and so we wanted to look at this
and allow these robot systems to ask for
help in states that are novel and risky
and allow that to improve their policy
and so we had this idea of using
interactive imitation learning where
if you remember from before we're
basically taking this behavioral cloning
approach we're going to directly map
from states to actions we're going to
learn from data and transfer that into a
policy but crucially we're going to
maintain our uncertainty
over
what we think we should be doing and use
active queries in order to try and
reduce that uncertainty and improve our
robustness over time
and so this is one of the example tasks
that we looked at where we're trying to
pick up this washer here on the left
place it on this peg down here on the
bottom and there's some kind of inherent
bottlenecks here where it's often
a little tricky to grasp that washer
exactly right and then when we bring it
over here there's like kind of a small
margin for error in terms of placing it
on this peg and so we found this a nice
test bed for testing out these ideas of
novelty and risk
in particular we call our approach
thrifty dagger so this is an interactive
learning approach where we're be
iteratively collecting data from a human
and using that to improve our model
and so we assume that we have this human
operator that we can kind of call into
kind of like a call center type approach
and ask them to come in and help us out
and in particular we're going to take as
input here our state
as well as some hyper parameter that
determines how often the human
wants to be you know bugged or kind of
how how much effort they can invest in
helping us out and we're basically going
to take these and we're going to ask you
know is the state novel and so here's an
example of a novel state where the
robots ended up grasping this watch in a
kind of awkward position and if we
detect this as novel we're going to ask
the human for help they're going to come
in tell operate the system get us
unstuck
if it's not novel we're going to then
check well is this risky
based off you know previous data
and we're going to assume here that we
have some binary indicator of task
completion and so we can train in states
that we've seen a lot of data this kind
of risk metric that tells us how likely
am i to be able to complete this task
from the state
as if risky we're also going to ask for
the human operator to come in and help
so for example in this case this washer
is in a really awkward position the
robot doesn't think it's going to be
able to complete this task
however if it's not novel and it's not
risky we're going to let the robot just
operate do its own thing and roll out
its policy
and crucially it's always going to take
the human intervention data use that to
improve its policy over time
and the reason we have this kind of a
gating approach is that if the state is
novel
we haven't seen much data there so we
really can't trust our risk metric
and so we're just going to like
immediately kind of say hey human i need
help
if it isn't novel then that's where
we're going to look at this risk metric
and say okay
how likely am i to succeed and if i'm
very unlikely i'm also going to ask for
help
so to kind of ground this so here's an
actual execution of the algorithm where
it starts off in autonomous mode it's
going to go down try and grasp this
washer but it misses
and so it detects now that this is a
novel state
it's going to ask for human supervision
we come and tell operate the robot at
some point it now detects okay like i'm
back in distribution things are not
novel risky anymore
takes over switches back into a toms
slot lets the human go do their own task
and finishes
the completion of the putting the washer
over the peg
here's another example where just right
at the beginning just due to the initial
state configuration the robot detects
that this is risky for it it doesn't
think it's going to be able to grasp the
washer
and so it asks for human assistance to
help it get lined up and then at some
point it detects okay
not risky anymore not novel anymore
switches into autonomous mode a human
can go back and do their own thing and
then the robot is able to successfully
autonomously complete this task
and we've also looked at kind of scaling
us up to more complex manipulation so
we're looking at this kind of deformable
manipulation we're doing this complex
kind of figure eight rope manipulation
kind of figure eight tying task and here
we're using this differential surgical
robot to give the demonstrations and
interventions
and we find that because this is such a
long horizon task and we're using you
know pixel input to try and train the
robot that behavioral cloning approaches
really just
can't make very much progress at all
with an equivalent amount of data but
what's cool is if we use kind of
equivalent amount of data but have
active queries so we have this system
actually asking for helping areas where
it needs help
we are able to get often really good
fully autonomous executions of this long
range task
what's also nice is like even at
execution time if the robot ever detects
that it's in like a novel or a risky
state it can always ask for help to get
unstuck so you'll see here as it's
coming around for this last bend it's
going to get slightly stuck
it switches back into supervisor mode we
apply just a simple correction and then
takes back over autonomously and is able
to finish the task
so
one of the motivations for like this a
project was this idea that
it's becoming increasingly more common
that we have
these kind of call center type
situations where we have one or small
number of people managing large fleets
of robots so all these companies up here
are actively working on are actually
deploying systems like this where they
have a small number of human operators
that are helping out robots whether it
be like autonomous forklifts or cars
and if we have a small number of human
operators you know managing a huge fleet
we really want to care about
how much burden we put on the person we
can't have these people micromanaging
every single robot and so to kind of
test out whether this thrifty dagger
approach really helped in these
situations we designed a simple user
study where we had 10 subjects come in
and we asked them to control three
different robots in simulation they're
all performing this kind of washer peg
insertion task at the same time
and
we looked at two different approaches
one was a robot gated approach which is
like thrifty dagger and we also compared
to some other prior approaches where the
robot is the one asking for help is
actively asking for help from the human
when it's not asking for help the human
can do their own task and so we gave the
human this task of doing this
concentration game this memory matching
game where you flip over tiles and try
and find matches
we also compare this to a human gated
approach
where the human is now micromanaging
everything they can see little thumbnail
views of all the different robots at all
times they can switch to whatever robot
they want at any time they can come in
and provide an intervention if they
think the robot needs help
and so you can see here the different
approaches that we looked at
and we found that so hd dagger is the
one where the human gets to decide when
they intervene safe dagger lazy jagger
and thrifty dagger all active robot
gated approaches where the robot decides
when they need help
and what's cool is when we looked at the
qualitative results after this we found
that overall people found thrifty dagger
to be much lower in terms of the mental
demand and much lower in terms of
frustration so they weren't constantly
being thrashed where the robot like was
queering for help letting them go back
to concentration then queering for help
again and they also were able to like
you know accomplish their task and the
robots only asked for help when they
really needed it and what i think is
even more cool if we look at the
quantitative results we found that
compared to the next best baseline that
thrifty dagger had 21 fewer human
interventions
and so this allowed the human to do
their task better they got 57 more
concentrations pairs found but there was
this really cool synergy where we
actually had the robots doing better as
well and so because the robots were
actively asking for help at the right
times the human was able to do their
tests better and the robots were able to
get more throughput as well
and so i think this is really cool
thinking about you know future
applications where i think more and more
like i said we're going to have small
groups of humans managing fleets of
robots and i think it's really important
that we have these robots ask for ways
ask for help in ways that you minimize
the super
visor burden but also allow these
systems to be you know robust and safe
cool so at this point i'd like to kind
of
think about like where do we go from now
so what kind of ideas am i excited about
in the future
and kind of popping back up to our
original statement at the beginning i'm
still very interested in this high-level
goal of using human input in order to
enable robust ai systems
and we've talked a lot about today kind
of learning models of human intent right
learning these reward functions from
human data how do we represent our
uncertainty over the reward function how
can be robust how can we actively reduce
that uncertainty
i think if we think about kind of this
end goal of trying to get these systems
out the real world interacting with
people there's a lot more than just kind
of understanding these reward functions
and if you think about these problems i
talked about the beginning there's all
sorts of different facets of uncertainty
that we really want these systems to be
able to deal with in order to be safe
and robust
and so i think there's a lot of really
interesting you know future directions
building off this work
and so if we think about uncertainty
i've talked a lot about how we can model
efficiently reward function uncertainty
or even like action uncertainty but
there's also uncertainty that these
robots are going to have over their
dynamics over how the world works over
object properties and affordances and
even uncertainty over human rationality
you know how rationals you human how
good are they giving me this type of
feedback
and ideally we can use efficient
interactions with people in order to
help robots
reduce our uncertainty and manage their
uncertainty in all these different
aspects if we think about human input
i've talked a lot about demonstrations
and preference rankings but there's so
much more that we can leverage in terms
of how we
learn from people on a day-to-day basis
so i think about how i might learn from
you or how you might learn from others
we often learn from natural language
maybe one might learn from like an
e-stop or i just tell you hey stop
you're about to do something bad
we can learn from corrections even just
looking at body language you know gaze
and facial expression
so i'm really interested in figuring out
how we can leverage and fuse these
disparate modalities in order to learn
better and reduce our uncertainty
i've also talked a lot about robustness
and in particular kind of the focus of
the talk today was on these ideas of
robustness in terms of performance
bounds
or being robust to a distribution
but i think robustness also is very
tightly coupled to these ideas of
verification and certifiability and also
explainability and interpretability
if we really want to have systems
aligned with what we want we need to be
able to like
introspect and see and make sure that
they can explain and then we can
interpret their behavior
and so some of the things i'm excited
about in the future
are
active queries that target different
types of feedback
and so in particular if we're learning
from multiple different ways a person
can give us information it'd be great if
these as systems could actively
ask not just for like good
demonstrations but even think at a meta
level of like should i even ask for a
demonstration now or maybe i should ask
for a correction and to do this you have
to think about you know how good is the
human at giving me corrections versus
demonstrations how much cognitive burden
is there going to be on the human
because i want to minimize that but also
how much information gain can i get
that's going to depend on you how good
the human is at giving these different
types of feedback
i'm also really interested in looking at
how we can leverage efficient
interactions with a human to enable rl
systems to more safely explore in
particular how can we learn constraints
from human interactions and efficient
ways that allow these systems to be able
to learn autonomously more efficiently
by
allowing them to kind of remove areas of
the state space that are are dangerous
or that might be constraining
and i think a lot of the stuff i talked
about today about learning reward
functions can be extended to learning
maybe constraint functions and things
like that
and finally i'm also very interested in
this idea of the interpretability and
explainability so we've done some work
in the past for like the t-rex paper
trying to kind of introspect into what
these like neural networks have learned
so one of the ways we looked at was like
finding observations that the network
predicted had like maybe a minimum or a
maximum reward so in this case this was
an observation that had predicted low
reward where you can see that these cars
are like making more progress
and so it's kind of falling back and
that was kind of a good indication that
this system had kind of learned the
right thing
however for this breakout example when
we tried to see kind of what things the
atari agent was paying attention to we
found out that really all it was
learning to do was just count bricks and
actually had never learned to detect
that moment when the ball hits the brick
and so this is like an interesting kind
of
correlation and a problem with this
system that we were able to kind of
uncover by doing some introspection and
so i think developing more tools that
allow us to figure out whether these ais
systems are doing the right thing for
the right reasons is very interesting to
me in particular i've done some
kind of preliminary theoretical work
doing my phd on this idea of machine
teaching
for
reward learning algorithms so how can we
design the maximally informative set of
demonstrations that we can give to an ad
system to teach them a particular reward
function i think you can also think
about flipping this on its head and
think about how can any system design a
maximum informative set of data to give
to a human to show it what it's learned
i'm also very interested in this idea of
trying to design these drivers tests for
ai systems so once again we've done some
really interesting preliminary stuff on
kind of the theory behind this idea what
we call value alignment verification
we're trying to design these really
efficient tests that we can give to an
ai system and based off its answers we
can verify whether it's going to be
aligned with a human's intent or not i
think there's a lot of interesting work
to go here where we can try and design
these unit tests or drivers tests for
these as systems
and so i think there's a wide variety of
applications that can benefit from these
types of approaches ranging from
robotics to rehab
and assistive robotics looking at
dealing with medical healthcare records
trying to learn good robust policies and
even online education a lot of my work
has been on how can we get a human to
teach a robot but i think you could also
think about how we get an ai system to
teach a human and kind of flip the
tables and i think there's a lot of
analogies that can be made
so with that i'd like to end by thanking
all my brilliant collaborators who have
had the privilege of working with and
i'd like to open up for questions thanks
yeah one of the problems i kind of
showed is that if we just have these
pairwise preferences
we're hoping that we can extrapolate in
the right direction but sometimes we
don't and so i think yeah leveraging a
little bit more information
i think could definitely make these
approaches yeah work even better
so we've looked at both yeah we've
looked at humans giving kind of
pedagogic demonstrations of like here's
something really bad do something
mediocre here's something like as good
as i can do we've also for like a lot of
our like big experiments just
checkpointed rl agents to kind of
simulate different levels
and yeah and we found like you know good
results using both approaches
but i'm definitely super interested in
the future in
yeah like digging more deeply i think we
haven't still done i think sufficient
work on the human factors side of this
in terms of seeing like how burdensome
is it for a person to give rank
demonstrations
i mean i think sorting a whole bunch of
demonstrations is probably not what we
want people to do but if i'm giving
maybe demonstrations in a sequence i
think it's very easy for a person to say
hey that was worse than last time or
whoops i really messed up for hey i like
did really good and give you kind of
these like pairwise preferences in a
sequence we've also found it's like
pretty easy for a person to kind of like
be pedagogic and say like hey let me
show you like something bad okay here's
something better you said something like
even better than that and so kind of
online giving these preferences
and i'm also very interested in
like just watching a person learn how to
do a task over time and seeing if we can
kind of use that to also get more
insight into what they want we've shown
good results watching an rl agent learn
over time
but haven't like extended that to
actually watching real people learn
which i think is like an interesting
kind of area to see if that would work
it's a great question yeah thank you
yeah
how do you solve for
a field where you what you want to
achieve better than human performance or
better than that state-of-the-art
how do you solve for
like
reaching another city of performance
when you use basically the
administration coming from
so can you if you use demonstration
coming for you yeah don't
race
level and how do you solve for it in
field where you want to reach by
another level of performance
yeah
that's a great question yeah so if i
understand what you're asking like how
do you how do you achieve this kind of
superhuman performance and so i think
it's it's difficult one of the ways that
we found that
is kind of a natural way to get around
that
is rather than kind of asking the human
for demonstrations and trying to
directly imitate that is we can ask for
these preferences over demonstrations
and then that gives us some sense of
kind of what things the human wave was
trying to avoid what things they were
trying to do
if i can kind of figure out what makes
one trajectory better or worse than
another one then hopefully i've kind of
attached on to like the key things that
make things good or bad and if i'm like
a really efficient or really fast or
really dexterous robot maybe i could do
the good things more and the bad things
less and so we found that this is like
one way of achieving that kind of like
better than demonstrator performance
yeah great question
yes
um so in these slides on uh on this like
efficient beige and t-rex
it seems that one of the benefits of
t-rex is that you need very few
demonstrations to achieve good
performance
but then you have this new development
of training the um the cnn to learn the
embedding so how do you
like how much more data do you end up
needing
that's a good question so for the
bayesian
rex work so we had we
actually used the same data that we had
collected for the t-rex paper
and then we just applied these
self-supervised and kind of unsupervised
task losses on top of that because we
had found that just kind of using the
supervised rankings to try and
learn this embedding
didn't work that well and so we wanted
to have like a richer embedding space
because
remember kind of the key idea here is
that we wanted a
rich posterior distribution that would
think about multiple hypotheses to
explain the data
and so yeah so we're learning this
latent space using these demonstrations
but also
taking the demonstration data and we can
train like an inverse dynamics model for
a dynamics model
we can do like these kind of
unsupervised kind of
like auto encoder type losses on that i
think
because we had like a wide range of
demonstrations ranging from like really
awful to like you know decent that gave
us a lot of good data for training these
auxiliary losses but i definitely think
yeah some situations you probably could
also benefit a lot probably in all
situations could benefit a lot from
having some offline data as well
which the agent could maybe explore
maybe with some intrinsic motivation or
some random interactions or maybe just
from like
prior data that you have i think you
could also use that data to try and
learn this this embedding
function and that will help you also do
the better bayesian inference
yes
okay now you should be able to figure it
out from here or
is that something that only the robot
decides when it doesn't need help
anymore that's a great question
so
yeah so what we looked at was where the
robot
got to decide
when to call in for help and the robot
got to decide when to like let the human
go back but i think that's like a really
interesting idea of having the human
like
say okay like i'm gonna like just like
let you swim now let's see how well you
do
and yeah we did not look at them i think
that's like yeah a really interesting
question about like
yeah how can the robot kind of use that
like signal from the human maybe to
learn better about
like yeah how much uncertainty it should
have in different states or what it
should do
and yeah i think that's i think that's
often what these people do right like
we're kind of like i'm teaching my kids
so i have three kids and yeah i was
teaching my daughter how to like bicycle
a couple years ago and you know i would
kind of be pushing her to be like
eventually i would like let go before
she said that she was ready and she
she'd be peddling along because i was
like pretty confident she could do it so
i think we as people often will like say
okay like now you try it now i'm gonna
stop helping you
and yeah i don't know much work looking
at that but i think that's really
interesting
yeah
another question would be we feel
different situation and like about
financial market rates reward and like
transporting the rubber transporting
some things how do you
kind of flourise the risk and in the way
that you input into robot like how do
you
categorize different situations in terms
of risk
yeah i think that's a good question
so
we're using yeah these financial models
of like value at risk
and there is kind of this like hyper
parameter for a lot of these models
which is like this alpha which kind of
determines like how far out into the
tail you kind of care about and
typically people just kind of set this
at like
like five percent i care about like kind
of the five percent worst case outcomes
that's optimized by conditional value
risk there but i think depending on the
situation
people's risk aversion definitely
changes and so
i think yeah figuring out algorithms
that can like allow you to calibrate to
a person's risk aversion could be a
really interesting
i mean we're kind of just like like
assuming in a lot of our work that
humans just like optimizing some reward
function we're trying to learn from
preferences like what that reward
function might be or from demonstrations
but you could also maybe try and learn
a person's level of risk aversion i
think from watching demonstrations or
looking at preferences and so yeah so
that's something that we've kind of just
like set is like this hyperparameter but
i think in practice you would definitely
want to adapt to the domain i think
that's like a nice thing is that if you
can adapt that you now have ai systems
that can range from being like purely
kind of like
maximizing expectation to like purely
being like robust and we have done work
looking at this kind of efficient
frontier between these two extremes
and so by varying
these different parameters in the models
we've actually looked at if you take
like a convex combination of
objectives where one objective is just
maximize expectation the other objective
is maximize c bar and you can take like
a weighted combination of these to kind
of carve out this pareto frontier of
policies that range from things that
you'll look good in expectations but
maybe have like wide tails to things
that like look worse than expectation
but like really hedge against risk
and i think yeah thinking about like
ways to like show that to a person and
help them figure out where on that
efficient frontier they want to be is
like an interesting area of future work
to fail when this is so like if you
don't have this is a function but like
the value that you're plotting in the c
bar plot isn't as clear as in
what do you do
is that is that question
um
like two different like
risk metrics these are like two
different like evaluations of risk
yeah that's a good question so we've
been looking at cases where we do have
this like scalar notion
of risk
and
yeah i'm sure someone's probably looked
at that but off the top of my head i
don't know how you might deal with that
but i think that's yeah an interesting
question
yeah
so
i might be this is not my area of
expertise so it may not be a great
question but a lot of these you're doing
with a lot of human interactions you
have the robots feeding people what
happens
when
you find your system and you have your
set of reward functions but there's like
a very
possible negative outcome
like where you won't status maybe your
reward sack function is satisfied but
the outcome is possibly
hurting some third member how do you go
about like
with the simple work functions you
provided like i guess is there any way
to make sure you don't like technically
you'd still be
completing your reward to some highest
level since you know maybe it's
building something you still built it
but in the process
like you're hurt you cause damage
somewhere else how do you balance that
with your award function or is there a
way to include that
yeah so i think one way
would be to take this like
robust optimization approach we've been
looking at where
it sounds like you kind of have these
two reward functions right under reward
function and i'm doing really good
underwater function b i'm doing like
terrible and so that's kind of the idea
behind this royal algorithm is i want to
optimize a policy that hedges against
these two different reward functions and
tries to perform well under both and at
least not terribly under either
and so i think that's like one potential
approach that yeah could be applicable
this kind of setting
where you have multiple different
computing objectives or competing reward
functions you want to make sure that
you're not performing terribly under any
one of them
but still you could add in like i talked
about before a little bit of incentive
just to perform you know well in
expectation because i think there's lots
of different kind of
i guess flavors of this type of
optimization but in particular something
i'm very excited about is like how do
you balance these computing objectives
i think the yeah the algorithm is one
way of doing that
um given time limit i guess that's it
for the question let things again
[Applause]